das thema sicherheit in all seinen
facetten ist eine der größten
herausforderungen unserer zeit wer in
diesem bereich beruflich tätig sein
möchte hat in österreich die wahl
zwischen privaten anbietern eine
ausbildung bei der polizei oder einer
verkehrten militärischen ausbildung beim
bundesheer
wer sich im schulischen oberstufen alter
noch nicht fix entscheiden wie lothar
kann für den gibt es seit kurzem die
piag die bundeshandelsakademie für
führung und sicherheit im
niederösterreichischen wiener neustadt
wir sind eine besonderheit wir sind da
sind wirklich eine ausnahme schule in
ganz österreich und vielleicht sogar
einen ganzen deutschsprachigen bereich
wir sind eine handelsakademie das ist
der kernbereich wie jede andere
handelsakademie organisiert dann mit den
besonderheiten des schulautonomen
schwerpunkt nämlich dass in diesem
schuljahr autonomen bereich führung und
sicherheit rezitiert vermittelt wird und
dann noch die zusätzliche schiene den
außerschulischen erweiterungs bereich in
dem die schülerinnen und schüler und
kadetten genannt dass die dann schon in
den sicherheitsrelevanten in der
militärischen bereich einige
vorkenntnisse erlangen können und das
heißt noch lange nicht dass eine
karriere beim bundesheer gemacht werden
muss auf der einen seite haben eben die
handels akademische ausbildung das heißt
auch wenn ich nach der schule dann
sachsa ich mag es eigentlich nicht mehr
habe ich eine berufsvorbereitung aber
auf der anderen seite haben wir eben
auch den militärischen zeigt dabei weil
für mich auch von anfang an gleich
möchten zum bundesheer meine familie ist
zum großteil bundesheer ich hab das
quasi im blut
ich habe das immer so vorgelebt bekommen
und es interessiert nicht einfach ein
großteil der schülerinnen und schüler
der bhkh stadt strebt eine karriere beim
bundesheer
daher wird der faktor disziplin dort
besonderes augenmerk geschenkt also ich
denke die schule ist nicht für jeden
etwas
da schon ein gewisses maß an disziplin
und auch an erziehung gefordert ist und
viele könnten die militärischen abläufe
als zu strengen finden
das habe militärisch nicht als es ist
schon ein bisschen härter daran dass
märkte fallen wenn man jetzt in der lage
ist mit thema kontrolle
aber es ist nicht so wie man sich am
anfang vorgestellt hat als ich habe es
ja auch viel strenger vorgestellt als es
jetzt ist was die jungen kadettin und
kadetten besonders anziehend finden sind
die vielen möglichkeiten sich sportlich
zu betätigen wir haben große
sportmöglichkeiten da wir einerseits
erinnern die große kraftkammer haben
des weiteren die dreifachturnhalle und
automatik haben wir ein freibad große
sportanlagen die auch bei der
militärischen fünfkampf
weltmeisterschaften genutzt werden sowie
das große areal des akademie parks dass
sie findet bringst du schon ganz schön
da haben macht man ganz für sport und da
wenn man nur fußball spielen werden die
anderen schönen seite macht und so
obwohl an der b hat im vergleich mit
anderen ausbildungsstätten mehr sport
angeboten wird versteht man sich aber
nicht als sportschule
unser ziel ist es eben keine
spitzensportler auszubilden sondern
schülerinnen und schüler zu haben die in
guten konditionellen zustand sind die
auch weil es ja einen zusammenhang
zwischen psychischen und physischen
leistungsfähigkeit gibt dass es daneben
er hat dort die eignungen da sind wir
herausforderungen im psychischen bereich
besser bestimmen zu können und für eine
ausbildung beim militär oder der
exekutive bestmöglich vorbereitet zu
sein
ich habe mich schon auch fürs bundesheer
interessiert aber ich hab den
exekutivdienst besser gefunden und
exekutive oder militär die
bundeshandelsakademie für führung und
sicherheit liefert nicht nur
grundkenntnisse
ich sehe einige dinge anders also dinge
die man als außenstehender jetzt als
wenn man irgendwas hört vom militär wo
man sich jetzt denke ich vielleicht mal
darüber nach ob es wirklich richtig ist
so ist berichtet wird und ich hab schon
eine andere sicht bei allen
unterschiedlichen facetten bleibt ein
ziel die bestmögliche vorbereitung der
jungen kadettin und kadetten auf ihre
künftige karriere beim immer wichtiger
werdenden bereich der allgemeinen
sicherheit das ist auch unsere
prioritäres ziel das wir zukünftige
offiziere unteroffiziere ausbilden die
dann eben auf der milak sind dann
natürlich auch wenn das bundesheer
sozusagen nicht als berufs geber in
frage kommt dass man dann in anderen
sicherheitsrelevanten berufung sei es
jetzt in perm innenministeriums in einer
sicherheitszelle einer
bezirkshauptmannschaft oder auch bei
einem privaten sicherheitsunternehmen
dass man dort aufgehoben oder jemand
bereits einstellen können
[Musik]